The topic for today is the
cultural theory of copyright.
In the previous segment
of the lecture, I
outlined the premises of one
variant of that approach.
We now turn to some implications
for copyright law of that variant.
The question I'll try to answer
is, if for our aspiration
were to foster A, opportunities
for the good life,
and B, the cultural conditions
that sustain such opportunities,
how might we adjust the law?
Listed on the screen are 13
zones of possible legal reform.
Items 1 through 8 involve
copyright law proper.
Items 9 through 11 involve alternatives
or supplements to copyright.
Items 12 and 13 involve other
intellectual property regimes.
In this segment of the lecture,
I'll consider the first eight
which, as I say, concern
copyright law itself.
In the third and last
segment of the lecture,
I'll consider, among other things,
the supplementary implications
alluded to in items 9, 10, and 11.
The remainder I'll leave
to another time and place.
This list of possible
zones of reform is meant
to be illustrative, not exhaustive.
It's designed to suggest how
the theory might be applied,
not to provide a comprehensive
recipe for rebuilding copyright.
The first doctrinal implication
is probably the most obvious.
Copyright law affects
education in countless ways.
We should adjust and apply
the law so as to enable, not
interfere with, the kind of
education I sketched and advocated
before the break.
For example, in lecture
number eight in this series,
I discussed the provision
of the US copyright statute
that attempts to facilitate
distance learning.
We saw that that provision,
popularly known as the TEACH Act,
is almost completely
ineffective in practice.
Its limitations are so severe that
almost no distance learning venture
relies on it.
Certainly I'm not relying
on it for this course.
Right now, meaning the winter of
2013, the World Intellectual Property
Organization is discussing
a possible model provision
that countries might employ in the
future to enable distance education.
When addressing this issue on
the national or the global level,
our goal should be to capitalize
on the extraordinary opportunities
for distance learning
enabled by new technologies
without, of course, corroding
crucial incentives to create
educational materials
in the first instance.
A useful exercise in
this regard might be
to ask what legal reforms would be
necessary to make possible an edX
course analogous to the one supported
by this lecture series but in a field
where the thicket of
copyrights is more dense.
Constructing an edX course that focuses
on law, and in particular on US law,
is relatively easy, because the
primary source of materials--
statutes, judicial
opinions, and so forth--
are in the public domain
in the United States.
Developing a similar course that deals
with contemporary art, for example,
or a modern social science
would be much harder,
because a much smaller percentage
of the pertinent source materials
are publicly available.
It's worth asking yourself
which of the rules
we have examined thus far
in this course would I
amend in order to make
such a course feasible.
In particular, how would I
qualify copyright owners' existing
rights to control the
reproduction, distribution,
and public performance of their works?
Here's another dimension
of the same general theme.
As we will see next
week, most countries now
have statutes penalizing the
distribution and use of technologies
that circumvent technological protection
measures-- in other words, technologies
that neutralize the forms of encryption
commonly used by copyright owners
and others to prevent
unauthorized access to
or use of copies of their creations.
Sometimes, those statutes
inhibit education-- for example,
by frustrating the work of teachers
and students in film studies courses.
As we will see, some exceptions
to the anti-circumvention rules
have already been carved out
so as to facilitate education.
We can and should create
more such exceptions.
Both of the possible reforms
I've discussed thus far
would curtail the entitlements
of copyright owners,
but enabling education does not
always point in that direction.
Sometimes, it might be
achieved by strengthening
the rights of copyright owners.
For instance, as we saw
in lecture number eight,
software firms frequently
strive to separate
the set of potential
purchasers of their products
into at least two groups, commercial
users and educational users,
and then to charge much higher prices
to the former than to the latter.
Here are two examples
you've seen before.
Of course, the reason that firms do
this is to increase their profits.
They're not altruistic.
Differential pricing of this sort,
they have discovered, is lucrative,
but it also redounds the
benefit of education.
Many more students and faculty are able
to obtain and use application programs
if the firms are able to maintain
these practices than if they are not.
Viewed through the lens of the
cultural theory I've outlined,
that's something we should
applaud and preserve.
How?
By adjusting legal doctrines to help the
software firms engage in this behavior.
More specifically, by
defending the rules
that inhibit arbitrage which corrodes
such differential pricing systems.
One such rule we saw
is the interpretation
of the first sale doctrine adopted
recently by the Court of Appeals
for the Ninth Circuit
in the Autodesk case.
That interpretation
enables software firms,
by characterizing their
transactions with their customers
as leases of copies of the
programs rather than as sales
of copies of the programs, to suppress
secondary markets in the copies they
provide to students and
teachers, and that in turn
will enable the firms to keep the
prices of those educational copies low.
And that's what we want.
I hasten to add that there
may be other implications
or applications of the Autodesk ruling
that we should be less happy about,
but this one seems commendable.
A less obvious, more general
application of cultural theory
concerns the
idea/fact/expression distinction
that, as we saw in lecture number
one, underlies the copyright
systems of every country in the world.
Copyright law, as you now know, does
not protect either ideas or facts.
It only protects original ways of
expressing those ideas and facts.
Many applications to this
principle are straightforward.
To take an immediate example,
the somewhat heretical claim
I made a few minutes ago, namely
that the Autodesk decision may
be consistent with a sociocultural
theory of copyright, is an idea.
You are thus free to describe that
idea to anyone else in any medium
provided that you use your
own words to express it,
but you may not without my
permission use the sequence of words
that I employed to express the idea.
Now in reality, as you
know, I have already
given permission for many
uses of my exact words
through the Creative Commons licenses
under which these lectures are
distributed, but ignore that fact
for the purposes of this illustrative
hypothetical.
Even though the general
principle is clear enough,
applying it in borderline
cases is sometimes difficult.
For example, what if the
particular way in which I've
expressed the defensibility
of Autodesk is
the only efficient way
of expressing that idea?
Then may you use my exact words?
Yes, under the merger doctrine.
What if my language is
not the only efficient way
of expressing the idea but one
of a small set of efficient ways?
May you use my formulation?
Not so clear.
Here's another edge case.
In the previous lecture, I described
the facts of the Harper & Row decision
in which Victor Navasky
took some 300 words
from President Ford's autobiography.
Among the most distinctive
phrases lifted by Navasky
where those in which President Ford
described his deliberations concerning
whether to pardon his
predecessor, Richard Nixon.
An illustrative excerpt from Navasky's
article is set forth on your screen.
"In justifying the pardon, Ford goes out
of this way to assure the reader that,
quote, 'compassion for Nixon as an
individual hadn't prompted my decision
at all.' Close quote.
Rather, he did it
because he had to, quote,
'get the monkey off my back one
way or the other.'" Close quote.
The language that appears in
bold and in quotation marks
was taken from Ford's book.
The remaining language was Navasky's.
Justice Brennan,
dissenting in this case,
contended that two aspects
of the copyright system
should have been construed so as
to afford Navasky some latitude.
First, says Brennan, some leeway must
be given to subsequent authors seeking
to convey facts, because those
wishing to express the ideas contained
in factual works often can choose from
only a narrow range of expression.
Second, Brennan contended that when
evaluating the fair use defense weight
should have been given both to the
factual character of the plaintiff's
work and to its public importance.
But even Brennan did not challenge the
claim that quoting 300 of Ford's words
in this way constituted
a prima facie violation
of section 106(1) of the statute.
Justice O'Connor, writing for the
majority, was even less forgiving.
Here's her language.
Quote, "The Nation has admitted to
lifting verbatim quotes of the author's
original language totaling
between 300 and 400 words
and constituting some 13%
of the Nation article.
In using generous verbatim excerpts
of Mr. Ford's unpublished manuscript
to lend authenticity to its
account of the forthcoming memoirs,
the Nation effectively
arrogated to itself
the right of first publication, an
important marketable subsidiary right."
Viewed through the lens of the
cultural theory I have outlined,
this is troubling.
Participatory political
democracy, as we've seen,
is one of the fundamental features of
an attractive and stimulating society.
Political democracy is only possible
if the citizenry is informed.
It's hard to imagine an issue
more central to political debate
and engagement than the precise
reasons why one president decided
to pardon another president for a crime.
Copyright law already
contains a device that
would have enabled the Supreme
Court to respect this consideration.
Language of the sort lifted
from the manuscript by Navasky
could quite plausibly have
been described as a fact.
Generalizing the point,
we or the Supreme Court
could have declared that
any language or material
essential to political
deliberation and civic engagement
is either a fact or an idea and thus
up for grabs in the political arena.
That would have left
Navasky off the hook
without needing to reach
the fair use doctrine,
and the result would've been to
encourage journalists in the future
to make more widely available analogous
utterances by major public figures.
Here's another example
of the same point.
You'll recall, I hope, our
discussion in lecture number six
of the case that considered
whether Martin Luther King complied
with the statutory formalities
established by the 1909 copyright
statute when delivering his "I Have a
Dream" speech on the Washington Mall.
Held, King had complied
with those formalities,
and thus his estate could continue
to assert a copyright in the speech.
Again, viewed through lens of cultural
theory, that outcome is problematic.
Broad public access to the
extraordinarily powerful language
in which King expressed
his vision of civil rights
would foster democracy
and civic engagement.
Rephrasing this consideration in
the language of copyright law,
shouldn't the text of the
speech now be considered a fact?
This principle need not threaten
the core of copyright law.
What type of candy Kramer dropped
into the body of a patient
during one episode of the Seinfeld
show does not constitute a fact,
but statements by public figures
essential to deliberation
and civic engagement should be.
A more radical extension of
the same general approach
would entail denying
copyright protection
to materials to which subsequent
authors must have access
in order to express
themselves effectively.
That principle arguably already
underlies not only the merger doctrine
but also the scenes a faire
doctrine, which as we've seen
denies copyright protection to images
or scenes that are as a practical matter
essential to work within
a particular genre.
The merger and scenes a faire
doctrines have cousins elsewhere
in intellectual property
law, for example,
in the rule that trademarks lose
protection when they become generic
and in the nominative use
defense also in trademark law.
If we interpreted or supplemented
merger and scenes a faire this way,
we would deny copyright protection
to works or aspects of works
that subsequent speakers need
to be able to speak effectively.
For example, we would permit
historians and appropriation artists
to use news photos that they
could not have taken themselves.
By contrast, if we were persuaded by
the logic of the Bridgeport Music case,
we would not permit rap artists
to sample sound recordings
without permission
because, as you now know,
the law, at least in the United
States, permits rap artists
and others to recreate those
recordings in the studios,
and thus they do not need access to the
originals in order to work effectively.
Next topic.
As you know by now, there
are two general regulators
of the scope of copyright
in the United States.
The first is the
idea/fact/expression distinction
which we have just reconsidered from
the vantage point of cultural theory.
The second is fair use.
How might cultural theory
illuminate fair use?
You will recall, I hope,
that when we were discussing
welfare theory in lecture
number four I suggested
that each of the various entitlements
that might be assigned to copyright
owners could be evaluated on the basis
of a ratio, the numerator of which
is the economic benefits that
entitlement would provide to creators
and thus the incentive
it offered to creativity
and the denominator of which is the
social losses that entitlement would
cause.
Generally speaking, we would like to
assign to copyright owners entitlements
to carry with them high ratios, ie
that, to use Louis Kaplow's words,
"give us a big bang for our buck."
And we would like to
deny to copyright owners
entitlements that carry with them
low ratios-- in other words, that
cause social welfare
losses that are large
compared to the economic benefits
they confer on copyright owners.
The fair use doctrine offers one device
we might employ for this purpose.
We could declare to be fair unauthorized
uses that encroach on entitlements that
have low ratios and declare to
be unfair unauthorized uses that
encroach on entitlements
that have high ratios.
A modified version of
this methodology might
be employed if our beacon were cultural
theory rather than welfare theory.
Specifically, we could declare
to be fair unauthorized uses that
encroach on entitlements that provide
copyright owners modest benefits
but erect substantial impediments
to the pursuit of a just
and attractive society.
On the other hand, we could declare
to be unfair unauthorized uses that
encroach on entitlements that impede
the good society in ways that are modest
compared to the benefits they
provide to copyright owners.
Here's an easy example.
Commentary and criticism are
culturally beneficial for many reasons.
They help consumers determine
which books they wish to read
or which films they wish to watch
before they waste time sampling them.
Equally important, engagement
in commentary and criticism
is enlightening, and we should look
for opportunities to facilitate it.
That in turn suggests that
copying copyrighted materials
for the purposes of
commentary and criticism
should be privileged under
the fair use doctrine.
Copying for parody would be
an especially clear-cut case.
As you know, parody is,
as a practical matter,
privileged in the large majority
of cases in the United States.
But not all countries are
as lenient in this respect.
They should be.
Here's a harder example.
You'll recall from the preceding lecture
that the meaning of the crucial term
"transformative" in US fair use
doctrine is currently unclear.
An interpretation of that
term that associates it
with physical modifications
has fallen out of favor.
But two other interpretations in
which "transformative" is translated
as socially beneficial and
in which it is associated
with cases where the purpose
of the defendant's work
is different from the purpose of the
plaintiff's work currently contend.
Some scholars and judges favor neither.
When I summarized this
debate, I suggested
that there is a fourth possibility.
The term "transformative" could
be translated as creative.
This was the interpretation I offered
many years ago in an essay on fair use,
and I continue to think
it's the best one.
A defendant's work should be treated
as transformative if and only
if it's creative--
somewhat more specifically,
if it either constitutes or
facilitates creative engagement
with intellectual products.
All of the cases that fall within
the green ellipse on your screen
involved uses that fit this definition.
All consequently should've been deemed
transformative, which would likely
have led to findings that
they constituted fair uses.
To be sure, this proposed
interpretation of transformativeness
would not be a panacea.
Although it would increase
the coherence and thus
the predictability of the doctrine,
it would still call upon courts
to make difficult decisions
concerning degrees of creativity.
This would be especially problematic
in the context of motion picture
adaptations of novels or stories.
How creative would they have to be
to escape liability if unauthorized?
A guideline that might help
when addressing such questions
would be that movies that
retell in a different medium
the same story told
in the original novel
would be insufficiently creative
to constitute fair uses,
whereas movies that told different
stories would be deemed fair.
So, for example, the Harry Potter
movies would require licenses,
while Apocalypse Now would not, on
the assumption that Heart of Darkness
was still in copyright.
But one can readily imagine
intermediate and thus harder cases.
In some, construing
transformative as creative
would help to reorient
fair use but, concedingly,
would leave many issues unresolved.
Acceptance of this
suggestion would increase
the set of circumstances in which
defendants could successfully
invoke the fair use doctrine,
but the theory I've outlined
is not always pushed in that direction.
In particular, viewed
from the perspective
of the theory I have sketched,
consumptive as opposed
to transformative uses
of copyrighted materials
do not merit as much solicitude as
the courts have sometimes given them.
Recall Justice Blackmun's
comment in the Betamax case.
"The situations in which fair
use is most commonly recognized
are listed in section 107 itself.
Fair use may be found when the work is
used 'for purposes such as criticism,
comment, news reporting,
teaching, scholarship,
or research.' Each of these
uses reflects a common theme.
Each is a productive use resulting
in some added benefit to the public
beyond that produced by
the first author's work.
The fair use doctrine, in other
words, permits works to be used
for 'socially laudable purposes.'
I'm aware of no case in which
the reproduction of a copyrighted work
for the sole benefit of the user has
been held to be fair use."
I am much of his mind.
While the productive-- in
other words, creative-- uses
of copyrighted materials
deserve lots of scope,
consumptive uses-- in other words,
uses for the sole benefit of the user--
do not.
Adoption of Blackmun's position would
lead to another heretical result.
The declaration in the Betamax case
that time shifting broadcast TV shows
and films is a fair use
might well have been wrong.
But hold on.
Wouldn't adoption of Blackmun's
position have doomed VCRs?
No.
It probably instead would have
resulted in a voluntary royalty system.
Purchasers of VCRs would
have paid a premium, which
in turn would have been paid to the
owners of the copyrights in the taped
shows and films.
This would have caused an
increase in the cost of VCRs,
and that cost might well have
reduced somewhat the pace
at which this technology spread, first
in the US population and then globally.
But from the standpoint of the
cultural theory offered here,
that would not have been so terrible.
A final comment about fair use.
At the end of the preceding
lecture, I suggested
that the US version of
the fair use doctrine
suffers from a fundamental defect.
It sets forth a set of four
factors that judges must consider
but does not indicate
why those factors matter.
The judges called upon
to apply the doctrine
thus must decide for themselves what
the goal of the copyright system
is and then construe the
factors to advance that goal.
Application of the doctrine is thus
very hard to predict in advance.
Adoption of the approach outlined in
this lecture could address that defect.
If lawmakers were willing to articulate
a vision of the sort offered here
and tie fair use to
it, the result would be
to reduce considerably
the notorious uncertainty
of this dimension of copyright law.
Let's now move on to the
sensitive subject of moral rights.
When set against the
backdrop of cultural theory,
one aspect of moral rights is
suspect-- the right of integrity.
As you know, the right of
integrity, when fully implemented,
protects artists and authors from
the destruction or mutilation
of their works.
The result inevitably
is to curb the interests
of the people we used to call
consumers to remix their creations.
Artists' interest in
self expression of course
deserves considerable
respect and protection
but perhaps not as much
as some jurisdictions,
particularly in continental
Europe, currently afford them.
In some contexts, the
artists' interests may
have to be tempered by legal recognition
of the equally important interests
of consumers in self expression
and the overall cultural importance
of semiotic democracy.
With respect to unique
or limited edition works,
perhaps preservation of the current
regime is, on balance, sensible.
No one should be permitted
to melt down or desecrate
one of the few castings
of Rodin's Thinker.
But when copies of a
work are not scarce,
modification and
remixing should be freer.
An example would be colorization
of black and white movies.
So long as copies of the
original film remain available,
we should tolerate, even encourage,
the creation and dissemination
of colorized versions.
Other dimensions of
moral rights, however,
stand up much better to scrutiny from
the standpoint of cultural theory.
The right of attribution, for
example, seems closely tied
to the fundamental human need
for self expression, the ability
to project one's identity into the
world and to be recognized by others.
Requiring recognition of that sort would
not materially impair the opportunities
for remixing and secondary creativity.
One doctrinal adjustment
that could accommodate
this insight would be to
add to the US fair use
calculus a requirement like that
currently in the United Kingdom's
fair dealing system, namely a duty
to give credit where credit is due.
Libraries contribute importantly to
public education, defined expansively,
as was suggested in the previous
segment of this lecture.
Thus, we should be skeptical of aspects
or applications of copyright law
that make it harder for
libraries to operate.
An example would be
public lending rights
which exist in Europe
but as yet nowhere else.
Such rights give copyright owners the
ability to collect fees from libraries.
If the libraries are able easily to
pass along the cost of those fees
to governments, which in turn pay
for them out of general tax revenues,
then the net result may not be bad.
Indeed, it may give rise
indirectly and inadvertently
to a form of governmental
funding for education.
But in most developing
countries, governments would not
be able to absorb these costs, and thus
the adoption of public lending rights
would seriously burden libraries
and likely force some of them
to curtail their operations.
That would be plainly inconsistent
with the cultural theory
and should be resisted.
The functions traditionally
assumed by libraries
are increasingly being assumed
by other organizations.
An example is Google, which sought
in its ill-fated Google Print Library
Project to make all books published
in the world widely available
in digital form.
This was a highly commendable ambition.
To be sure, there were opposing
considerations, most obviously
the interests of the
authors and publishers being
appropriately compensated.
The best way of reconciling
these goals was far from obvious,
but one maneuver was promising.
Oren Bracha proposed that we
accept in this particular setting
an opt-out rather than an opt-in rule.
In other words, Google
or other organizations
should be permitted to digitize books
and make the digital versions publicly
available unless and until
the copyright owners object.
Shifting the burden to the copyright
owners would have huge social benefits.
Most importantly, it would enable
widespread distribution of so-called
orphan works, works that may still be
in copyright but whose owners cannot be
readily identified.
Opening up all such works for public
use unless and until the owners
made themselves known
and objected would do
much to facilitate the dissemination of
knowledge critical to a good society,
and the burden on copyright
owners would be slight.
This brings us to formalities.
In lecture number six, I
suggested that many scholars now
believe that the modern trend
of abolishing formalities
as preconditions to the acquisition
or enforcement of copyrights
is regrettable.
The cultural theory sketched here
suggests some of the reasons why.
By granting copyrights
automatically to creative works,
we needlessly limit the
scope of the public domain.
And by failing to require compliance
with a comprehensive registration
system, we needlessly frustrate
many potential licensing deals
that would enable socially
beneficial activities.
Cultural theory can
also lend some support
to the shaky arguments I discussed
at the end of lecture number eight
in favor of compulsory licenses.
Specifically, two kinds
of compulsory licenses
look somewhat better when
viewed from this angle--
those that enable modifications
of copyrighted works
provided that the modifiers pay a
governmentally-set fee, and those
that give a break to
educational activities,
such as public broadcasting.
The former, such as the
cover license in section 115,
had the effect of increasing the
diversity of cultural products
available to the public.
Think of the richness of
the menu of renditions
of classic musical compositions
that the cover license has enabled.
The latter, of course, facilitate
education broadly conceived
and an informed citizenry.
A few minutes ago, I mentioned an
example of differential pricing,
specifically in the context of
educational discounts for software.
I now want to return to this
issue and address it more broadly.
Differential pricing of
copies of copyrighted works
is a very complicated subject
when viewed from any angle.
Assessed from the standpoint
of cultural theory,
it offers some intriguing possibilities
but also poses some dangers.
The principal opportunity
is that differential pricing
can have the beneficial
effect of equalizing access
to entertainment and informational
products across income classes
and countries and thus promotes
the kind of distributive justice
that figures importantly
in cultural theory.
This possibility is suggested by
the facts of the Kirtsaeng case,
which as you know is currently before
the United States Supreme Court.
Supap Kirtsaeng is a student who
financed his education in large part
by persuading his relatives
living in his native Thailand
to purchase inexpensive copies of
textbooks that had been manufactured
and sold in Thailand and ship them to
Mr. Kirtsaeng, who was then studying
at Cornell University
in upstate New York.
The large differential between
the price at which the books were
being sold in Thailand and the
retail price in the United States
enabled Mr. Kirtsaeng
to make a healthy profit
selling the books on eBay for
somewhat less than the US list price.
The issue currently
before the Supreme Court
is whether John Wiley, the owner
of the copyrights in the books,
should be able to stop this practice.
Admiration for Mr. Kirtsaeng's
entrepreneurial spirit and unease
concerning the magnitude of
the damage award to which he
is exposed if he loses suggests
the answer should be no.
But consider what will
happen if Kirtsaeng prevails.
Publishers, feeling
generalizations of his conduct,
will almost certainly reduce
the price differential
between the US and
poorer countries, thus
rendering arbitrage of the sort
he engaged in less attractive.
The publishers could achieve this
by lowering the US retail price,
but for obvious reasons that's unlikely.
Instead, they will probably raise
prices in Thailand and other developing
countries.
The result is that the
residents of those countries
will face higher financial
hurdles when seeking educations.
Assuming that we wish to apply our
cultural theory on a global scale
this is an unattractive outcome.
For similar reasons, we
may wish to acquiesce
in the technological protection
measures that help film studios engage
in so-called region coding of
DVDs and now Blu-ray discs.
The effect of those systems is that
the disks sold in one region cannot be
played on players that are
sold in a different region.
One of the goals of such systems is
to enable the studios to sell discs
at lower prices in poorer regions
than in richer regions without fearing
importation of the cheap versions
into the wealthier regions.
From the standpoint of
distributive justice,
it seems a good thing, not a bad one.
But differential pricing
is not an unalloyed good.
Viewed from the standpoint
of cultural theory
it has at least four
potential drawbacks.
First, it sometimes results in
a constriction, not expansion,
of the set of people to whom
the good at issue is provided.
This all depends on
the shape of the demand
curves in the subdivided markets.
Second, as Wendy Gordon
observes, differential pricing
can increase what she
calls the granularity
of social life, the sense that all
of our conduct triggers microcharges.
Third, as Yochai Benkler
and Eric von Hippel contend,
differential pricing can corrode
a culturally beneficial practice
and spirit of altruistic
sharing-- in other words,
giving away your stuff for free.
Last but not least, the
dream that currently
bedazzles many copyright owners of
slicing their markets ever more finely
creates a powerful incentive to
collect extremely detailed information
concerning the habits, incomes,
and wealth of those customers.
The result is a serious risk to
privacy, one of the conditions
that, as you know, figures in
our vision of the good life.
How can we balance these
competing considerations?
No blanket solution is readily apparent.
The set of rules governing differential
pricing that, all things considered,
is most conducive to the good society
unfortunately varies by context.
This concludes our examination
of the possible implications
of the particular variant
of cultural theory
that I have outlined here for the
reform of copyright law proper.
After the break, I'll consider a few
ways in which the same theory might
be applied outside
copyright law and then
consider some overall objections
to this whole approach.